for this quiz you'll be building a new
family tree okay well not really but
you'll be building a new Dom tree which
is kind of like the same thing you've
got a pretty simple Dom here there are
two nested divs and then another div
with the ID of family one and under
family one you can see the children and
their children but there's another
family and it's going to be called
family two it doesn't exist yet and
you're gonna need to build it you can
see family two has a child and that
child has two children so for this quiz
I want you to build on the existing Dom
tree so that the final one looks like
what you see here these are all divs
that you'll be adding and you can see
their IDs written right here